greetings everyone i will be covering a
variety of interdisciplinary areas from
the ics security point of view
in order for us to be able to answer to
this question do we really want to live
in the cyberpunk world
uh during the talk i will be sharing
only the actual stuff and their
potential implications in terms of the
ics cyber security uh maybe you know
them all
but mostly we deal with the details and
lack of seeing the bigger picture when
we're dealing with the iss security also
i want to point out that these are my
own thoughts and my own way of
interpretation
of the advancements in technology and
their correlation with my own
experiences obviously yours might be
different than mine but i want to raise
an awareness about these subjects
and in my opinion we should not consider
these subjects separately or different
areas than the ics world
uh before i dive in
further though allow me to introduce
myself my name is max but you can simply
call me merckandclick because i have
been known to being able to click from
the early ages of my life
i'm a computer engineer with the
master's degree in cyber security i
promise i primarily focus on the cyber
physical systems as well as the wider
networks and the isp implementations and
their security as well i work as an ics
penetration tester in the barricade
cyber security where i get to do a lot
of penetration testing to a rich variety
of cyber physical systems
now let's quickly define what cyberpunk
is so that we are on the same page when
it comes to answering our title question
the term cyberpunk was originated back
in the 80s as a sci-fi dystopia where
the society is dominated by computer
technology and big corporations where
everything
was interconnected in some way or
another
in short we can describe it as the era
of high tech load life and
in the essence of it we can simply call
it like the hacker culture
back in the 80s ics operation and
management was considered as an
extremely sophisticated and serious area
of work which is true even today scada
was in place and less people had to do
the dirty work on the field
what we basically do on the ics is that
we process the inputs
and take actions accordingly it was
mostly done by hand from the control
center
but hence the term control system
implies right
things were less digital back then there
were nixie tubes lots of switches and
indicator lights etc uh nearly all of
these components were hardwired right so
it was quite hard to maintain and
troubleshoot in case of an incident
and also because of that the cyber
security was not big of a concern other
than the fight physical violations
also there weren't many rf applications
back then even though there were some
examples
and rf devices were not big of a
security concern
because of acquiring an rf equipment was
not feasible in terms of size and the
cost
and also in 1979 modbus was introduced
by modicom and brought a new way of
communicating with rot devices and most
of these principles of ics still applies
today
so by looking from the 80s to now
maybe we are living in the cyberpunk
world and there is only one way to find
out so i would kindly ask you to put on
your power gloves and let's have time
all right 1980s to today
the basic principle for the ics did not
change a lot but the way of implementing
it
really changed over time
even though it changed in drastic ways
we still have the modbus family uh it's
mostly modbus tcp but we get to see it
very often on the ics realm and isis
security still relies on the physical
security and
security throughout security approach
is a must when it comes to the ics
security
and there is a rapid transition to the
wireless we are
planning to convert most of our field
devices into a wireless
medium and we all know what wireless
means it's accessible to anyone
we now have the iiot as well which we
will cover
soon
and we have some models that we
implemented such as purview
but for now we get to see a newer
approach
for ics implementation and it's more
cloud-oriented architecture
we are planning to carry out our
operations and our
data to the cloud as well as any other
systems and also now the ics world
relies on the geographical information
systems
where we can use the gps and other
technologies that are out there
so let's start with the real-life
example for the ics world uh for those
who are not familiar with it
i will be giving some examples and some
possible attack vectors
in terms of ics security
so let's take a look for the gas
distribution systems uh
we try to
distribute the gas uh by going through
different steps where we tend to reduce
the pressure up to a point where we can
use in our household
uh the gas is being distributed in
really high pressures for to achieve
high volumes and we have to reduce it
down to a point where we can use it
which is around one to twenty for 21
millibar
and it starts its journey with the 60 to
75 bars atmospheric pressure as as long
as we
keep uh reducing that pressure the
natural gas has this unique property of
uh being cooled down
about a half a centigrade degree celsius
for every atmospheric pressure you
reduce it to
we use gas chromatography uh that's for
to analyze the compounds within the
natural gas
it's mostly done in on real time uh
obviously the natural gas does not
consist of only single compound it's a
mixture of compounds we have to measure
it and most of the
uh the
distribution
companies are being you know charged
based on those values and we use flow
computers sensors and all that kind of
crazy stuff to achieve that but also it
comes with the price and we have to use
the gas analyzers which has to be on
some kind of embedded operating system
but in my experience i have mostly seen
them using windows ce
also another interesting feature of the
natural gas
that is that not contain any odor so you
can't really detect by smelling the
natural gas i know that you know what it
smells like but that's not by its
default we have to use some kind of
alteration to achieve that and we use
some special liquid that is called the
thd
uh for to order that natural gas that is
being transmitted but the thd
is so potent that only one drop of it
can authorize about 2400 meter cubes of
gas
which smells awful already
so in order to authorize the natural gas
we obviously use the scada system and we
have the plc or rgu
which is connected using the wireless
modem it claims that we should cover it
in a safe area but i don't see the
definition for the safe
as
for the example with the florida water
supply attack where the hackers were
able to you know manipulate the system
of the mixture of the lye on to the
water supply and changing the value to
100 to 11 000 parts per million and the
same principle can be used to manipulate
or use as an attack vector for the
authorization technologies as well
so we as you can see from the you know
data sheets we use the old hardware they
are connected either using the serial
port or some kind of modem and
most of them are still operating from
the modbus protocol
so all in all we mostly use the same
principles of hacking when it comes to
conducting a pen test on the critical
infrastructure
there are also some hardware related
techniques but are mostly overlooked
security incidents in the past has shown
us that the air gap approach of ours is
not invulnerable and in my opinion it
won't be
sufficient in the future as well
it has been known that there are
countless possibilities to try if
someone with malicious intent ever finds
a way into the ot network
uh triggering a denial of service on a
field device is the least that can be
done
there were incidents on the power
distribution lines where attackers have
accessed the infrastructure from a
remote location where they made their
way up to the ot network and in the end
they successfully manipulated the
syncrophasers
there are also some cynical methods for
compromising the ot network and air
gapness a single board computer with
built-in mobile data implementations can
be really hard to detect especially if
you have the
network infrastructure is not well
established in a security oriented
fashion
i have seen folks who are in charge of
dlt network made some ignorant claims
about that the specific vulnerability
won't cause any security problems to
their network
uh they make these claims based on the
trust of the air gap implementation but
as soon as they see a demo about the
possible implement implications of the
spc implant
which i randomly place it on an
unexpected field switch and ask them to
pinpoint it by physically or off of the
network traffic
uh you get to see the fear in their eyes
and how how hard it can be to detect
such devices if you don't have a fully
mature ot network
on top of that reminding them about the
past incidents of insider attacks
and the
you know the new supply chain attacks
they
then tend to grasp the idea of why that
ms something something vulnerability
needs to be addressed regardless of the
internet connectivity
uh so most common hardware related
techniques is to
mess with the firmware and the serial
communications on the embedded device
itself
we fire up our logic analyzers bus
pirates and many other fancy gadgets to
have a foothold on the device itself
when you have an access to devices such
as modbus gateways or the media
converters which are also overlooked and
are considered crucial most of the times
what do we get to see most
cw259 hard-coded passwords
on top of that rfcoms are causing a
greater risk than ever before thanks to
our sdrs it is possible to interact with
rfcoms nearly every portion of the
spectrum depending on your hardware
obviously all you have to do is to set
up your sdr to the desired configuration
so that you don't need to buy out of the
box radio which is designed to work
under a specific band by the whole help
of these devices such as hecarif not
only we can receive signals but also we
can make transmissions too uh therefore
attacks such as gps spoofing are out
there for nearly a decade now
and the rf attacks can cause very
devastating outcomes especially for
maritime operational technologies and
such
now let's take a look for the emerging
technologies so that we can see these
advancements and there are similarities
with the ics security
tendency to make everything smart is out
of control there is iot and iiot where
an ordinary raspberry pi is being
used in heavy duty industrial
applications
we use cheap esp devices to monitor and
monitor our hydrophonic food forms or
control our buildings and cities
and i understand that being able to grow
our food without using any soil and
stacking them up like server racks is
tempting and cool but i have doubts
about their security implementations too
i said that there aren't many security
percussions in place on those systems
even though they are part of the
critical infrastructure as far as i know
we have to be able to keep away the
attackers from manipulating the
nutrition injection systems by using the
similar techniques as we have seen in
the florida water supply attack
also people are now carrying a local
area network of interconnected devices
right on their bodies as a result of
that internet of medical and internet of
health things have emerged
if you were to look for frequency
allocation for those medical devices and
their telemetry bands it is clear that
they are well within our reach with our
sdrs
ibm these are not something new but they
are also being rf enabled in vast
amounts uh doctors now can monitor your
health data like an ics operator they
can upgrade your ibm d's firmware or its
parameters remotely
insulin pumps are widely used today and
if you look at the functional diagram we
have rf links temperature sensors and
motor controllers
it's like a mini ics of its own in some
sense but they are designed not to have
an air gap to function
and
there are the
implantable rfid devices despite the
fact that many people purchase and
implant them by their own will
i don't see why not that we will be
asked to have such devices on us if we
ever decided to use the airports where
rfid tunnels can check our health and
vaccination status in an automated
fashion
so by putting all these together
remote healthcare became more effective
we can simply call it the backroom
healthcare
i don't see any obstacles where
adversaries are analyzed and make
real-life correlations with the victim's
historical heart rate data so that they
can design a better spear phishing
attacks even a read-only data can be
used to leverage those types of attacks
another cool topic
bci the brain computer interfaces like
the human machine interfaces are here
too
they are basically reading your brain
activity and decoding them to the
signals to operate a desired external
device
and there's this non-invasive vcrs are
like putting on a head and you can take
it off and desired but on the other hand
the invasive applications of the bci
needs electrode implantation directly
into the cortex wouldn't that be great
to operate the scada systems without
even moving a muscle
so one example of the bci technology is
the open source project called the
openvci
and so this technology can be easily
mapped or programmed in a way to allow
us to handle
certain parts of the ics operations
and also there are already some products
out there where their primary concern is
not the health rather to take us one
step closer to the cyberpunk world
so just to be clear these technologies
are promising for sure and i don't want
to sound like i'm against them but
potential vulnerabilities that might
affect these kind of technologies and
their implications are kind of scary all
i'm trying to explain is that ics
operators or people who are in charge of
critical operations may have these kind
of interconnected devices on them
therefore their ivmds could be used as a
pivot point to compromise our critical
infrastructure
and when we are going to put this
possibility of our security policy
equations i don't know but
if so let's say we decided to do that
what are we going to do ask for an api
key to their ibm d so that we can
include them in our pen testing scope
anyway moving on
simplest form of attack against such
devices is battery drain attacks uh you
can consider them as denial of service
but for ibm these and all you have to do
is simply trigger the rf module over and
over again as if you were about to
communicate with them
a case study and well detailed post was
published recently it's a great example
for capturing and decoding an rf signal
that is being transmitted off of an
ingested capsule that is being used to
measure and record the ph levels inside
the body
utilization of autonomous vehicles are
also on the rise for both public and
industrial use and certain in some
certain industrial areas they are being
used as a part of the production line
therefore in my opinion avs should also
be included in the overall evaluation of
those processes
not so long ago we have witnessed a
drone attack targeting the saudi aramco
soil processing facilities this may be
categorized as a matter of national
security and not the responsibility of
the ics governors but in the same time
custom-built drones with autonomous
flight capabilities can be used to
attack our facilities and drone jammers
won't be able to intercept them
even if we decide to place them in our
infrastructure as it was like an ot
equipment yet i can't see any possible
prevention mechanism and
that we can use
other than the offensive approaches
which is whole another discussion to
make
i think we won't be able to hide behind
the air gaps false sense of security
anymore because we are transitioning
into a phase where our most critical
equipments are being hyperconnected more
and more every single day
there are millions of people with
medical implantations and a lot of those
people might be working in your
infrastructure without even you knowing
it
his or her or her device might have some
vulnerabilities and if you get to think
about that
these devices have all sorts of
pre-programmable components like
microcontrollers and fpgas right
so even today we see a lot of windows
xp's and windows 7's with our
uh with very old vulnerabilities on them
inside our ics networks and companies
who are not willing to reinvest millions
of dollars just to erratic eradicate
those potential security flaws and keep
on running the process and
risk acceptance right so there is no way
of knowing that your
operator might being used as a gateway
to exploit those systems as well
and attackers won't have to find a zero
day to further penetrate into dlt
infrastructure because they are
vulnerable already
let's look at this issue from uh
different perspective what if that
vulnerability of ibm d device is simply
unupgradable and you know the hardware
is not sufficient enough to have that
new firmware
and the health insurance won't pay for
the new surgery
and that operator of ours might accepted
the risk personally but
uh wouldn't that decision will also put
rics into risk as well
so that's a question that we need to
consider
and also i'm almost certain that we will
get to see ransomware issues on medical
implants
the cloud infrastructures
that operators of ours might have been
hospitalized and desperately waiting for
ransom to be paid so that he can get his
insulin pump working again
and as i mentioned earlier i think
there are huge similarities between the
ot and these technologies that i have
been explaining and these technologies
are not designed in a security oriented
fashion
my point is that we should and must
actually put our security considerations
at top priority
if we are going to interconnect
everything so basically we simply cannot
deny these facts
are here
one last concern that i have is how are
we going to train more cyber security
experts who are capable of tackling
these challenges you know ics security
is one of those areas where there is
lack of labor environment
it's not as easy to train qualified
workforce for the ics as it is in id10
testing
there are definitely some great examples
of ics exercise test beds but you have
to be
in the vicinity of those environments to
be able to work with them you know most
of the time
and
if you get to think about many of us
dragged into the cyber security field
mainly as a result of our curiosity
uh you know we break things and to make
things and more young people will feel
the same curiosity too
uh when we made a mistake back then the
worst case scenario was having a blue
screen of that vsod but that potential
hacker of ours might get tempted by
neighbor's son's ivmd and
unintentionally caused irreversible
problems
okay now for the last part the future i
will briefly talk about what we might
end up seeing
when you put all these technologies
together and you know hyper connect
everything together and
the beginning would be the transhumanism
or human 2.0
this is where most of the sci-fi
dystopias are born
augmentations are like
upgrades for the humans so you know you
can consider them like what steroids are
today
not only the people with medical needs
will buy them but people are expected to
use augmentations just to be more
superior
by using the technologies that are
already here and trying to guess which
direction they're headed i don't see why
not people and their augmentations could
be manipulated in a way that they have
not intended themselves
it could be as simple as pushing a
button in the skater room which they
shouldn't or turning off a nuclear power
plant which they are in charge of
and you know what they say hackers gonna
hack and cyberpunk world if it ever
happens in my opinion which is already
happening
will be a new area for the cyber
criminals thus we need to be prepared
and we need to
start working way our way up to
executing security measures for those
subjects to come
we definitely are not in those good old
days where there were no mass data
collection was in place
but the last amount of data that is
being collected now also includes a very
personal and real-time details about us
and in my opinion
neglecting the possibility of these data
could ultimately affect our way of doing
things in terms of
ics cyber security
i hope i'm not hacking too much time uh
this talk wasn't about you know
creating a debate about these subjects
but just sharing my thoughts
and i'm simply unkindly asking you to
open your eyes because
those stuff are not far away from now
most of them are here already so
be prepared and we need to get ready for
them
obviously there will be some denial
phase it's understandable but it's the
first step towards the acceptance
you needed the references and i would
like to thank you all for your time and
attention
and
do send me an e-back email about the
uh do we really want to live in the
cyberpunk world question and hope to see
you in the void